john john i wanted to start
with you here because correct me if i'm
wrong but i believe this is your
first time as a series regular so
what was the the most exciting part
about getting to flush out a character
for the entirety of a season
it's great that you're in more than two
episodes
and it's great that you have a lot of uh
um monologues uh
it's scary sometimes but it's it's great
and also
it's wonderful to think that ryan
trusts you to to be able to play this
and i mean to be just invited in his
world
you know the way he tells of the stories
it's just
all my friends want to be in his world
and i'm in it
and that's that's just wonderful
given the fact that ryan is the kind of
person who likes to
work with the same folks again i know
american horror story has
more seasons and both of you have been a
part of that so if you were to take
one member of the ensemble of ratched
who has never been in ahs
before and bring them over there who
would you choose and why i think judy
davis should be on that because
yeah she should do everything but uh
yeah i could see her being a great i
don't know
serial killer maybe who knows vampire
given the fact that this is an
incredible ensemble here
and you guys get to work with many
members of it
of the group who would you say is the
member of the cast that challenged you
guys
most and for the better you know what
i'm going to say is
sophie okanina she she plays this
incredible uh person with uh multiple
personalities
and um she did it completely
effortlessly like
she did it in this way that uh felt like
she wasn't even
uh working and um and so
it was just a really kind of it was just
a really cool
thing to watch her work um and to kind
of try to match
um the kind of the level of uh
expression that she was able to to
portray in the matter of a few seconds
she's going from
a completely different person to a
completely different person
um and i'm just i'm just really excited
for the kind of world to see her
performance
a lot of my scenes were with her as well
um
she every time we would rehearse even
just rehearsals
she would never she would not mark and
and
a lot of her scenes together are very
heavy and even rehearsal she's crying
and i go
oh my god you know save it
roll the camera yeah yeah and
her bag of tricks is really
she brings a big bag of tricks with her
it's
just like what finn said it's her range
her range is just
amazing i'm so glad you guys highlighted
her i think she's a force in literally
everything i've seen her in and she
deserves even more credit than she gets
uh
finn for you i did want to ask about
working with sarah again because mildred
and
edmund's relationship is very important
to the show a major driving force of it
and it's very complex too
so do you think it was important that
you were cast opposite someone that you
already had built that rapport
connection with yourself
i think it definitely helped i i think
that
there was a level of like not having to
break the ice with her
that that we were kind of could just
dive right into the
the red meat of the relationship um
and i i i i just always
admire her work but it's just very nice
like feels very cool that
that i get to say like i i kind of
i know i know her like i literally know
her
so it's like that that is just
it just makes things so much easier and
um
i could make things harder you know like
there are other actors that you'd be
like oh god
i would you know that's terrifying um
but she's such uh an an exact
and such a detailed actor
uh and so and this part she's not always
this way you know you've seen her like
if you see mrs
america you know it's like a whole
nother side which i thought was
incredible
but this is a much more kind of reigned
in um
tight-fisted character that is like
she's holding a lot back
and edmond was kind of a more caged
animal that was more impulsive and and
did
uh i didn't always know where he was
going to go so
i i thought that was a really fun
dynamic between the two of us
to play with this sort of uh restraint
and sort of
feral quality of his that i think was
like
it was like we were dancing thank you
guys so much for your time today and
huge congrats on the show
thank you very much